>> RAMAN: Thank you for coming, everyone.
My name is T.V. Raman. I'm a research scientist
at Google. And with me, I have my office mate
and co-hacker, Charles Chen. This talk is
about accessibility to web 2.0 applications
for all users. And we'll talk a little bit
about--I've got my outlines for--we'll talk
a bit about--so that--we'll start to talk
of structure and we'll talk about what we
mean by the word accessibility for the purposes
of this talk and specifically in terms of
enabling web 2.0 applications to be usable
by everyone. And by everyone, I mean everyone
starting with your grandparents who can probably
see perfectly well but, say, "that computer,
you know, I can't read that screen," all the
way to users who are blind, who might be deaf,
who might need other forms of special support.
This talk is specifically about applications
and web applications. So we'll spend a few
minutes talking about the context in which
web apps are put together and therefore the
technology enablers that we all have at our
fingertips in order to enable such widespread
accessibility. We'll talk about an open source
framework that we at Google released about
six months ago into the space that Charles
and I have been working on. We'll show you
code examples. We'll show you demos, you know,
the effect of using the framework on a lot
of Google properties. We'd like to keep this
interactive. If you have questions, you can
hold them to the end or if possible you can
ask it during the talk through, that's fine.
Don't just raise your hand and be polite because
I will rudely ignore you. So wave, make noises
or whatever. So the way I usually structure
my talks is I make sections in the talk 'cause
that's how I end up thinking of my talk. So
we'll talk--let's go to the first section
of this talk where we'll talk a little bit
about accessibility and web applications.
So flip to the first slide there. So what
exactly do I mean by accessibility? I'm sure
those of you who have seen the theme of accessibility
and have interest in this field have heard
a lot about regulations, that it's a good
thing for you to make your applications useable
by the widest number of people. But if you
look at the space, a lot of the work, in terms
of saying what accessibility means, is often
couched in terms of web content and in terms
of regulations and fairly high level concepts
such as make sure that somebody who cannot
see color can appreciate your side or make
sure that somebody who cannot use a mouse
can use your application. I tend to phrase
accessibility slightly differently. If you
think of what all of us as web users and web
developers do, when we develop web content
and we develop web applications, the original
goal of the web and all the architectural
principles that underlie the web dictate that
you never ask who, you know, you never design
your thing assuming only a 21-year-old who
speaks English and who can see will use your
site. If you do that, you are actually shooting
yourself in the foot with respect to taking
advantage of this wonderful platform that
we call the web. The web is a wonderful platform
and better than anything that has gone before
it because of its reach with respect to the
audience you are garnering. And that reach
is both global in terms of countries. It's
international in terms of languages. It's
all age groups and it's all capabilities.
So the way I explain accessibility when I
talk about this at Google to the web community,
both within and outside Google, is think about
it as the long tail of users. So where we
as Google excel at the long tail of content
in finding you that web page that is the best
for you. It might not be the best for anybody
else in the world, but you as a user don't
care. You as a user care that for the task
you are doing, a particular page happens to
be the best for you. And we as Google excel
at finding that in search. In accessibility,
I think of it as, we as Google, trying to
serve each user what is the best thing for
that user. So in that context, let's then
talk about what accessibility is and what
tools users have. So if you look at mainstream
user interfaces, your average desktop user
interface, your average web interface. If
you look at the interface you have to the
rest of your world, those user interfaces
play--assumes that you have certain abilities
and based on those assumptions place certain
demands on you. So your traditional interface
assumes that you can see the screen. When
you walk up to this building, that door assumes
that you can push it. That's the user interface
and that's the set of capabilities it assumes
that you have. Now, when there is a gap between
those demands that that environment places
and the abilities you have, there is a problem.
And you typically solve that impedance mismatch
by augmentative technology. So I move around
with a guide dog. I might use a cane. When
I use the computer, I have my computer speak
to me. If I have a hearing impairment, I might
look at captions. If I have a motion impairment,
I might use some other devices. So that's
what you are talking about in terms of bridging
those gap for accessibility. Flip to the next
slide. So how does all this actually work?
So coming down to--to, you know, the rubber
meets the road, you typically have augmentative
software, and sometimes augmentative hardware
that essentially helps the user bridge those
gaps. Now, you bridge the gap with spech,
you have screen readers for the blind. You
have other--you have self-voicing browsers.
You have extensions to browsers that make
the browser talk. You have environments that
automatically speak applications. All the
way down to, you have captioning software
that allows you to, you know, add captions
to videos, all of those things. Typically,
these things work with hand in hand with API's
in the platform whether it's Linux, whether
it's the Mac, whether it's Windows. So for
instance, any of you who have a Mac Book,
you'll be surprised to know that if you hold
the command key and a particular function
and boot up, the Mac will actually come up
talking. That's in the true sense OS-X [INDISTINCT].
Windows, there are a number of screen readers,
there are all of these things. And so typically,
in the past, when you heard the term web accessibility,
you also heard a few myths that I'd like to
dispel before we start talking web application.
So flip to the next slide. So one of the constant
reason why you hear myths about web accessibility
for the--especially for the blind in terms
of "Oh, please don't do that on your page.
If you do that the blind user won't use it."
And a lot of cases those are true. But in
a lot of cases there is confusion. So the
reason for that confusion is, it's useful
to understand how this technology evolved.
So the web essentially took off just at the
time that blind users were coming to handle
graphical user interfaces. And the way speech
interfaces for the blind were done for the
GUI was to say that we will track the focus
and speak the thing under the focus. So the
web came up at the same time, and as you all
know, in '95, the web was about documents;
it wasn't about applications. And so, a lot
of work that went into sort of saying what
web developers ought to do focused on this
notion of content and a user reading a document
by moving focus. And so that's really how
the space got defined. And then very silently
starting in 2000, we started adding small
pieces of interactivity to the web where today,
when you go look at Gmail or Google Reader,
those are not documents. Those are full fledged
applications, and one of the reasons why AJAX
applications has been a challenge and that
will be the focus of all of this talk is that
when people try to address an application
as a document, you end up with significant
challenges. These are not--these are mostly
usability challenges as opposed to accessibility
challenges. AJAX applications, done right,
can be just as productive for somebody with
a special need as they are for somebody who
has a 20/20 well-sighted, you know, mouse-enabled
user. And that's really the point I'd like
to make during this talk. I'll flip to the
next slide, which is the bridging of the gap
slide. So what is this? What do I mean by
bridging the gap? Here is something that I
have come to realize in the last 10 years
as I worked in this space. So the document
is then--is the interface, it's a cliché
that we all know from the work at Xerox PARC
in the '70s. And it was the motivational theme
behind WYSIWYG interfaces, WYSIWYG authoring
and eventually the GUI. The document is the
interface. And the web epitomizes this even
more by moving away from monolithic applications
that "create documents" to a world where you
take the piece of information that you're
working with and you embed just enough interaction
into that information that your user needs
at that time. So this is how html works. We
basically take a document object model which
is the DOM and we program against it, add
little bits of interactivity to it. So the
document is the interface at that level. But
if you look at the user interface that is
realized as a consequence, the user interface
is not a document. If anything, the user interface
is at best a series or collection of documents.
So you go to your Gmail inbox and you do a
search and then, you know, you look at the
thread of mail about the Google I/O developer--I/O
developer conference, right? Now, that particular
view of your Gmail, you know, inbox that you
have brought up in that set of what messages
are highlighted could be serialized as a document.
But the Gmail interface is not a document.
And to sort of build good accessibility into
it for the blind, to build a good auditory
user interface requires us all to think of
these things as applications, not documents.
Let's flip to the next section of the slide
that talks about web applications. And the
reason I put the section together was not
because people, especially at this conference,
it's, you rarely need--don't need to say this
because all of us are web developers, but
it still gives us all the sense of perspective
to step back and ask what is it that led to
web applications as they are. And based on
those architectural principles, what are the
opportunities that we have in order to enable
this. So from here on, for the rest of this
talk, think web applications and accessibility
to user interfaces and web applications, not
documents. So what is the web architecture?
The web architecture is a very loosely coupled
architecture. So in the '90s when I used to
work in the space of doing good auditory user
interfaces for applications, I used to tell
software developers, you know, couldn't you
separate the visual interface that you do
for your application from the actual engine
of that application, so that I can then build
a good auditory user interface without rewriting
your entire application. Now, in the world
of monolithic software that we lived in in
the '90s on the desktop, this was a very tough
task, people would laugh you out of the room
immediately. They would say, "You mean, you
want us to separate this big lump that we
have into two lumps, then we don't know how
they work together? Go away." Now, the Web
architecture, because it's based on HTTP,
HTML, and URLs, with a lot of intelligence
living up in the cloud and a fairly thin to
a fairly rich user interface delivered into
the browser, forced us as software engineers
to create that separation. We factored that
out. And so, today, there is a Gmail interface
for mobile, there is a Gmail interface for
desktop. Nobody forces you to use the Gmail
interface that works on a large screen from
a mobile device. If we did, you would go use
some other mail service. That tells you something.
We have moved from a generation where we built
user interfaces that were one-size-fits-all
large kitchen sink interfaces to user interfaces
that are lightweight, that are agile, and
that get delivered to users in the form they
want. And that, I believe, is the big opportunity
for enabling accessibility to users with different
needs that we can leverage. Flip to the next
slide. So, the other part to keep in mind
as we think about how we do this going forward
is to step back, understand what all of us
as Web developers have achieved on the Web
and apply those lessons to now what--it's
not just the mainstream, but the long tail.
The coolest thing about Web 2.0 is not the
fact that, you know, you can make things animate
and jump up and down with a piece of Javascript.
That's not a visual coolness. The cool thing
about Web 2.0 is that its Web artifact built
out of what I call Web parts. So, Web 1.0
was all about us geeks bringing content online.
You know, we'd get very excited to see that,
oh my god, look, now there's a job search
site online, and look, all the weather forecasts
are online, oh, look, New York Times is online."
That was about content coming online, and
I think of that as Web 1.0. The world of Web
2.0, aggregations and mash ups, widgets and
gadgets, open social applications, all of
these things are no longer simply about bringing
a piece of content from the physical world
onto the web world. It is about taking things
that are already on the Web and building new
things out of Web parts; building them out
of HTML, out of CSS, Javascript, REST APIs,
Web APIs, things that where people give you
ATOM content, give you JSON content. These
are things that are on the Web that which
we are building Web parts. So one of the questions
we asked as we put together this open software
framework that we'll be talking about is,
"How do we then build specialized user interfaces
out of Web parts? How do we enhance Web applications
using Web parts?" And so that's really the
thrust of this whole talk. Flip to the next
slide. So what I want us--the challenge I
posed to myself and others in Google engineering
when I started at Google about three years
ago was to say, if you look at what the Web
community, the AJAX community has achieved
incrementally starting in 2000 all the way
up to the first generation AJAX apps, Gmail,
and then Google Maps later on, we essentially
took the browser that started off as something
designed for a world of global hypertext documents
and we turned it into a global runtime for
highly interactive end user applications.
And we did that with rubber band and chewing
gum and paper clips and all of these things.
Now, we have nicer things like Google Web
Toolkit that let you develop these things
much more nicely. How can we as engineers
use that same level of innovation to enable
very good interactive solutions for users
who cannot see, for users who cannot hear
and use the Web model as supposed to the old
desktop model? So, the Web model, to me, is
all about agile development, developing quickly,
using Web technologies to deploy it on the
Web, using the Web to garner user feedback
and then iterating quickly where the user
doesn't actually have to buy a piece of software
every three months or ever six months, where
the user doesn't have to do a new install
and wipe his disk out, where the user just
gets improvement. So that's also what we are
looking at in this work along side making
sure that the AJAX applications that until
now have been decried as "don't do AJAX apps,
it won't work for a blind user" can actually
be done such that they work for all users.
So, having said that, let's sort of see--talk
a little bit about the underpinning technologies
that are helping us bridge those gaps. So,
if you think of the HTML DOM and Javascript
as the assembly language of the Web--I talked
briefly earlier about why AJAX applications
in the 2004-2005 timeframe proved a significant
stumbling block for blind users using adaptive
technologies from that era. What happened
was, as I said, those technologies treated
Web pages as documents and knew about the
few interactive elements that HTML had in
terms of form, fields, and anchors, and, you
know, select boxes, whatnot. But when you
write an AJAX app, we do two things. We--the
A is the important part, the asynchronous
part, which means that pages are changing
under you as you interact with them. Also,
we add behavior to what looks like a piece
of text through a Javascript event handler
and adaptive technology that is just looking
at the document as a document doesn't know
that what you have is a checkbox or a widget.
So, some time in summer of 2003, I think,
from memory, I and a few others at IBM--at
the time I was at IBM research, we started
a piece of work for adding a couple of op
codes, if you will, to the assembly language
that is the HTML DOM. So, if you think about
what you need to discover that a piece of
text that has suddenly become a menu is a
menu, and if you ask, "What do I as a programmer
need to be able to figure out that a menu
item in a DHTML application is disabled or
enabled", right? At a programming language
level, this comes down to enabling reflection.
And so that's what was added and has, today,
become a specification called Accessible Rich
Internet Applications Specification from the
W3C. It's called ARIA for short. It's a very
simple spec. As specs go--specs are hard to
read. So here's your 2-minute tutorial on
it. It's basically a set of very simple DOM
properties that enable reflection. There's
three classes of things. There is a rule attribute
that allows you to ask something, what are
you, and it can reply to you, saying I'm a
checkbox, I'm a pull down, I am a tree control.
There are dynamic properties that tell you
the state of something: is this button pressed,
is this menu open, is this menu item disabled?
And there are--there is the ability to setup
observer-observable relations using a mechanism
called Live Regions. What that does is that,
say, you have--you create a classic mail application
where you're showing two panes. One pane is
showing a summary of your inbox, and the other
pane is showing the thread that you currently
have opened. And then as you move your selector
in the summary pane, the message that is being
displayed in the right pane changes. So basically,
you need to know that there is an observer-observable
relationship between these two panes if you
are going to be able to write software that
speaks that updated message on the right pane.
So that's what live regions do. Thus technology
is now being implemented in pretty much all
the browsers. Firefox was the first to implement
it; Opera followed; Web Kit just started implementing
it; and IE8, in its beta, has announcement
an early implementation. So that's fairly
full coverage. Flip to the next slide. So,
the ARIA op codes that I mentioned give us
as Web developers a leg to stand on with respect
to communicating all the coolness in our Web
applications to various adaptive technologies.
But if you think about it--so let's say you
go write your cool music sharing app. A user
who comes to your site doesn't come for the
pleasure of checking a checkbox, right? The
user comes there to use your application.
So though something like ARIA is needed for
making sure that all the basic widgetry in
a GUI application that's done as a Web app
work correctly with adaptive technology, that
is not enough. So as an engineer would say,
that's a necessary condition that's not a
sufficient condition. The sufficiency condition
is actually what I call building usable UI.
And so, at this point, we are back to talking
usability as opposed to, you know, just users
with special needs. A usable UI is one that
enables your users to use the application
end to end. And there's this very difficult
to quantify thing, which is, at the end of
the day, they are happy. The sort of happiness
is something that, you know, we have Google
forecasts on our lot in terms of users being
happy. It's not a tangible thing, but it makes
a huge difference in how many users come and
use your thing. I mean, Apple always had the
same thing in terms of it gives you pleasure
to use their devices. And I believe there
is a similar happiness factor with Web application
that comes from "It just worked. I got my
job done." It is not glitz that makes you
happy, it's when things work that you get
happy. So, flip to the next slide. So, in
all my experience of doing good auditory user
interfaces, there are about five categories
of things that you do in order to make sure
that an application works really well when
you are not looking at the screen. And by
the way, a lot of these things are actually
useful for power users as well. So, when you
look at this category of things that I'm enumerating,
they're not just for special-needs users.
They're really help your power users as well.
So the first among these is sort of an obvious
one that everybody in the accessibility field
tells you, which is make sure that all your
visual elements have good metadata associated
with that. So people tell you that, but unfortunately,
they stop there. So that's not enough. That's
sort of a starter. The next thing you need
to do is to ensure that all user actions produce
appropriate feedback. This again sounds like
a no-brainer from a usability perspective.
The reason it's important to reiterate this
from a blind user perspective is that often
that confirmation, the fact that I deleted
this mail message, the deletion happened,
is usually indicated by just a visual change,
and we need to make sure that the right AJAX
DOM bits are used so that whoever is using
speech output gets the right notifications.
The next bit is actually quite interesting,
which is, if you think about how a complex
visual layout works for you, it works because
your eye gets random access to different parts
of that display. And we'll demonstrate all
of these with very concrete examples very
soon, when you start showing your code. But
think about how you look at the railway time
table. Think about how you look at the bus
time table. Think about how you look at the
stock chart. You never read those things like
documents. You do not read them left to right,
top to down. In fact what happens is you actually
look at them and they essentially function
as a mini-data base. And so there's all this
information sitting on the screen and your
eye essentially does a quick query where it
says, "What does Google stock at right now?"
Or I need to be at Mosconi at nine in the
morning. When is the train from Mountainview
leaving that gets in at nine? Oh, yeah, there's
a train getting in at eight-fifty. Or when
does it leave Mountainview? And then you say,
"That's the train that I'm taking." Right?
So, this is something you absolutely have
to enable in order to build a user interface
that actually works for somebody who is using
a nice eyes-free interface as opposed to,
you know, it's out of just, okay, you can
muddle your way through it. And guess what?
What I just said applies to a cellphone as
well because you don't have a big screen,
the whole time table doesn't fit how you are
going to change it--use that train time table
on your cellphone, and you're going to search.
And then finally there's, you know, getting
to different pieces of the page with the keyboard
rather than relying on random access with
the mouse and pointing it. And so, that's
the category of five things we do. And so,
flip to the next side. And so, about October
of 2007, last year, Charles and I started
a framework called AxsJAX. We came up with
this name saying AJAX and we wanted to inject
the accessibility support into AJAX applications
without disrupting how those applications
were done. And so one fine morning over a
good Google breakfast he and I doodled on
a paper napkin and came up with a logo that
Charles can model for you. And so, the idea
that we said there's this car called Web Tutor
II and that's on the move which is powered
by AJAX and, you know, if you are driving
a car and, you know, you need to keep moving
and need to do a quick fix, you jack it up
and push something under it and so we put
the access under it. And so the goal of the
AxsJAX framework is really to protect and
insulate, abstract the web developer from
the minutiae of the couple of op codes in
the DOM that I talked about. But lets you
as the web developer focus on--when the user
deletes a mail message in my web app, I would
like whatever adapter technology he is using
to say message deleted. That sounds like a
no-brainer, but this is again a hard problem
because the screen readers that various users
use, each of them do not actually give you
the developer an API that says speak the screen.
They basically say you put it on the screen
and we will talk, which means that as an application
developer you are sort of down in this write
once and debug everywhere model, where you
write your code and then, you know, if you
actually are paying attention to the issue
then you are running one screen reader and
say, "Oh, that screen reader said that, it
worked." And then go to another screen and
it doesn't say the same thing. And screen
readers are expensive. And so this whole thing
basically, web developers throw up their hands
and say "it's too painful, I'd like to do
the right thing, tell me what and we'll do
it." And then if you throw lots of guidelines
at them that all content based then there
are consequences in what we saw in 2005 and
2006 all the AJAX apps are completely unusable
if you couldn't see. And so what we want and
what we have done in that as we are doing
two things in AxsJAX framework: One, is to
abstract out details of the audio spec by
building on Aria, the browser are implementing
Aria, the screen readers are implementing
support for Aria but we are giving you as
a web developer and not just you, but us as
web developers as well because Charles and
I have been using our framework to build the
things that we'll show you. We are giving
ourselves higher level of calls that allow
us, in JavaScript, to say speak this DOM node
or speak this piece of text without worrying
about is it on the screen or should I tell
the screen reader to go read, you know, the
contents that are on the top left corner or
something like that. The other thing we are
doing with this framework is, what I said
earlier about how web development works, which
is it's all about agile development and deploying
it on the web and using web technologies to
deploy and iterate and improve. And so the
open-source source framework in October and
all of the code is checked into the Google
code project and these slides have a link
to the--that you will see. Basically just
search for AxsJAX and Google and you'll find
it there. One of the advantages that we got
out in this project that is actually quite
nice with respect to distributing software
using the web is that because it's checked
into Google code all of this code is basically
what I call URI addressable. A simple fact
right, is Google code user subversion. Subversion
is accessible via HTTP, each of those things
are no-brainers but when Charles and I check
in code, each of this scripts have a URL.
And we inject access--we inject these scripts
into applications when we're prototyping through
Greasemonkey which is another wonderful piece
of software. And so you connect the dots.
You connect Google Code and you're going connect
SVN, you connect JavaScript script checked
into this SVN repository that are accessible
via HTTP URLs and you then connect up Greasemonkey.
And you suddenly get this prototyping environment
where you can--Charles and I can check-in
an improvement to a script and our end users
get them immediately. And then what we do
in the spirit of agile development is that
as our scripts get robust, get user feedback
and things work, then we go back and check
it into the main code repository for whatever
app that we are extending and then basically
from the external we leave the code on codegoogle.com
and so that you the developers can study how
we did this. And then we basically pull out
the Greasemonkey loading magic for that particular
app and everything continues to work. And
so the lesson is; insulate your users from
the fact that today you are in development
mode and tomorrow you are stable, but get
the advantage of what you have built for the
users as quickly as possible because there
is no point in me and Charles building this
in our office and waiting for a year for it
to get perfect and then give it to the users
because the users need it now. And what we
have learned and I know this firsthand is
that users need these solutions badly enough
right now that they would rather have it as
you are building it and use it and give you
feedback rather than you sort of saying I
know best and I will develop it in secret
and then give it to you a year later. And
so we will start showing you some demos and
code right now. And so the first set of demos
and examples I'd like to talk about is in
the context of Google web search. Now web
search, today we use a few AJAX bits in web
search for enabling some features but traditionally
nobody ever thought of the result page as
an AJAX application. In fact our results page
still works in down level browsers like Links
today but one I'd like to show you as we sort
of go through the set of slides and show you
the code running is that by using AJAX in
conjunction with AxsJAX framework that gives
you all the goodness of Aria under the hood
you can actually significantly enhance the
user experience for something that is very
content rich like the Google web search results
page. And the user experience that you get
as a blind user or as a low vision user with
this, you would never go back to using a document
oriented interface which was, you know, what
everybody was using until we started with
this work. And so the code that I'll show
you does all of those things that I talked
about. The Google results page is a very rich
page when you do a results search for flowers
or something like that; you see ads which
depending on what you are doing are extremely
useful. And so for instance if I'm shopping
for something, I often go look at the Google
ads because the ads are actually much easier
to read than something on the manufacturer's
website which is a lot busier typically. If
I'm looking--if I'm doing research on something,
then I want to go look at the search results
versus the ads, if I want help in rephrasing
my query then I want to look at all the related
searches that Google provides. If the first
set of 10 results doesn't contain the answer
which fortunately given our search quality
is rare but does happen, I want to go to the
next page of the results. As a blind user
I don't care if it is the next page of the
result I just want the eleventh result. I
don't want to be getting a fresh page and
then go hunting in it for the first result
again. And when I do a search from a good
auditory user interface point of view I just
want the first result spoken. Again from an
auditory user interface point of view, that
result as it is displayed has a lot of things
in it. It has the main title of the research
and the result. It has a snippet which is
a body of text about the result. It has a
bunch of links. What is the most common action
that you do when you have that result? You
hit enter and you go to that site and I want
that? And so I go and let's bring up our demos
here and we'll talk through this I'll let
Charles do a bit of talking so that I can
drink some water and he'll also show you some
code snippets.
>> CHEN: Okay, so, I'm going to turn on the
speaker and do a search for flowers. And so
I've typed in flowers into the search field.
And I'm going to do a search and you'll see
that what happens next is exactly as Raman
had described earlier.
>> COMPUTER: Flowers, roses, plants.
>> CHEN: So notice how when that search result--the
page of the results came up, the first result
was spoken. And you also noticed that it magnified
the text there but it didn't magnify the whole
screen, it just magnified the one result that
the user is interested in. Now if I want to
proceed to the next result rather than trying
to scramble around and find where the next
result starts, I can hit a single key and
get to the next result. And so I'm going to
do that right now.
>> COMPUTER: Flowers, plants, roses, and [INDISTINCT].
>> CHEN: And so you see it just went onto
the next result. Now if you keep on going
and you reach the last result of this page,
why should the user have to dig around and
find the link for the next page? To them it
should be as simple as just going to the next
result, and the logical thing to do at that
point would be to take them to the next page
and read the first result to them. And so
I'm going to do that now and I'm going to
be going pretty quickly and so we can get
through this. And so...
>> COMPUTER: [INDISTINCT] flowers vineyard
[ph] [INDISTINCT] flowers.
>> CHEN: And notice how now it loaded up the
next page for me and it read the first result.
>> RAMAN: The secret of building a good auditory
interface is that you should also learn to
stop the speech immediately quickly and notice
how quickly the speech flashed and that's
important.
>> CHEN: Yes, silence is golden. Now the other
thing is as Raman had mentioned, sometimes
you actually want to see sponsored links or
related searches and not the main result set.
And so we can do that as well with again a
single key press. And so I'm going to go through
sponsored links right now.
>> COMPUTER: Free delivery [INDISTINCT] same
date flowers deliv--flowers...
>> CHEN: So I can do that. And if you are
wondering how the user can discover these
keys, we've kept a convention of letting them
type the question mark and always hearing
the available keys.
>> COMPUTER: The following shortcut keys are
available. Down, [INDISTINCT], cycle back.
>> CHEN: And so it will keep going.
>> RAMAN: So there are two things I'd like
to sort of describe in this context. One is
the end-user's mental model, and the other,
which is the web developer's mental model
so that--all of you as web developers, when
you sort of look at a complex webpage, and
look at--think of the AxsJAX framework, and
sort understand what you do. So let me first
talk about the end-user's model. The end-user's
model is that, at any given point, you can
do a set of things based on where you are,
and you discover that by hitting the question
mark. You discover the things you can do and
those things that you can do typically walk
you through the contents on a page, such as
moving from result to result or moving from
ad to ad or moving from result--search--you
know, search refinement to search refinement.
That's the end user's mental model, notice
that this sort of matches what we as web developers
have often--have always driven for, for the
mainstream user who can see. So you go through
a lot of trouble in terms of building your
DOM and building your CSS [ph] so that the
human eye can do what I just said, which is
either move from result to result, or jump
to the ad, or jump to the various search refinements.
That's the end-user model. How do you do this
as web developers? The way you do this as
web developers in the AxsJAX framework is
to leverage a piece of software we wrote in
the framework called AxsNAV. What the AxsNAV
module does is it takes from you a declarative
representation of how you want to be able
to have the user navigate that page. And the
way you should think of this as developers,
is that if you think of that big complex DOM
that you have built and laid out, that's a
collection of nodes, think of there being
many logical trails or hiking paths, or whatever
you want to call it, through that DOM, so
in the case of Google results as you saw,
one interesting trail is one where you walk
along all the results, and other interesting
trail is one that where you walk along the
sponsored links. And it's useful to know what
trails there are on a page. So if you look
at that fragment of XML that Charles is showing
from our core depository, what we do is we
declare in this fairly simple XML thing that
we cooked up, this can be XML, this can be
JSON--it's basically a piece of declarative
data that was factored out of our code after
we wrote the first few examples and then sort
of stepped back and stared at it to see what
we had done as software engineers. So in the
declarative format, you basically say, here
are the trails in my page, you basically use
x parts to define--identify the node sets
that make up those trails. You say what keys
you want to use as forward/back-keys, for
moving on that trail, and optionally, you
can specify what action you want executed
when your user moves through that trail. That's
your classic visitor pattern. So notice by
just doing that, by defining this--what we
call them a CNR file for counter navigation
roads, by just defining that, the AxsJAX framework
actually does a lot of the work for you. So
for an application like Google web search,
most of the work was actually done in that
CNR file. Now, at this point, you can basically
extrapolate to many, many content rich sites
on the web that can leverage this--everything
from the New York Times, to CNN, to Wikipedia,
to Gmail, to a lot of things, right. And so
if you look at the Google code repository
for AxsJAX, you will see that we have scripts
for Gmail, we have scripts for Google Reader,
we have things for Google books, we've done
a whole slew of things, and what is happening
as we go through these, is that as these things
get stable and ready for broader deployment,
they basically go back into the product. So
I'd like to spend some time talking about
Google Reader, which is one of my favorite
AJAX applications and one of the first things
that I actually voluntarily did inside the
browser--other than browsing web pages, simply
because it was such a well done application.
So those of you who have not done--used Google
Reader, it's a very good feed reader and sort
of your--the amount of things you read, once
you use Google Reader, goes up by an order
of magnitude. It is a power user application,
which means that a lot of functionality in
that application--all of that functionality,
in fact, are actually driven from the keyboard.
You can use the mouse, but believe me, you
will be more efficient if you use the keyboard.
Everything is keyboard-driven, you subscribe
to a bunch of feeds, you browse through your
feeds, you open a feed, you browse through
articles and you go bang, bang, bang. And
its gears enabled, it has offline storage,
all of that wonderful stuff. So Charles and
I used the AxsJAX framework in--last fall,
October, November last year to add in, sort
of, a good auditory user interface to it,
and then we integrated that support into the
application in March and we're shipping the
thing now. What we'd like to show you is what
it feels like to interact with Google Reader
that is AxsJAX enabled and you will see a
lot of what I was talking about earlier with
respect to--as a web developer, audio--speech
enabling, voice enabling access enabling your
app without worrying about adapter technology.
And yet, having it work completely seamlessly
with adapter technology. At the end of the
day, this is what standards give you, and
this is why having ARIA as a standard, that
is implemented by the browsers, by the--adapter
technology vendors and used by us as web app
developers gives you, and what we have been
doing is, building a high-level abstraction
over it as I said and so things like the Google
Reader can just say speak this text and it
speaks it. So let's go to Google Reader--
>> CHEN: Alright, so I'm going to bring up
Google Reader, and I'm going to activate a
version that has the support in it--
>> COMPUTER: Click here for ARIA enhanced
Google Reader.
>> CHEN: Okay, so I'm going to activate that.
>> COMPUTER: [INDISTINCT] 850, BT8--
>> CHEN: So now, notice that what happens
is it speaks where the visual highlight is,
so first off, I'm actually going to make the
highlight a little bit larger, and more visible.
So now you see that it's enlarging the area
that I'm highlighting and as I navigate through
that with reader hotkeys, you'll see that
it's reading where I'm at, so--
>> COMPUTER: Cool Tools 28--
>> CHEN: Okay, so I'm going to open the official
Google blog.
>> COMPUTER: [INDISTINCT] Official Google
Blog 18.
>> CHEN: Okay, now I'm going to open this
feed, and show the articles.
>> COMPUTER: Articles loaded.
>> CHEN: Now, notice that it just said "articles
loaded" right there. That text is nowhere
on the screen. However, through AxsJAX, by
issuing a speak text call, it calls its assistive
technology to say that, even though it's not
displayed. Well that information isn't needed
for a sighted user who's looking at the screen
and can just visually tell the page is loaded.
It's important to provide that auditory feedback
for a user who's just doing an audio interface
and is only listening to the thing--
>> RAMAN: So this is an interesting bridging
technology that we have built, which is traditionally,
screen readers, as the name implies, read
what's on the screen. Now, often, putting
information on the screen just so a screen
reader reads it to somebody who cannot see,
detracts from your--the mainstream UI that
you're building, but as Charles pointed out,
you can see that the article is open. There's
no point in wasting screen real estate, saying
article's loaded. So this has been an interesting
challenge in the past, it's been a challenge
even in the case of desktop applications.
And one of the neat things that is there in
the AxsJAX framework is this ability to use
the DOM and then trigger speech feedback from
the adaptive technologies. So whatever deep
dark magic is involved between DOM op codes
and screen reader implementations is abstracted
away from you. And we've done the testing
to make sure that it works with all the shipping
screen readers so you make your call and it
works. Do you want to talk [INDISTINCT]?
>> CHARLES CHEN: Yeah. So we're going to go
ahead and just show that it can read articles
as well so--
>> COMPUTER: 9:45 a.m. three hours ago, happy
birthday, Google years.
>> CHEN: So you can just use the hotkeys again
to go--
>> COMPUTER: May 27, 2008, yesterday, many
here, many [INDISTINCT]
>> CHEN: And so by doing this, you have access
to all the functionality of Google Reader
and you can just hear it.
>> RAMAN: Shall we do any translation?
>> CHEN: Yes--
>> RAMAN: So, while Charles brings up the
next demo, this is something interesting in
terms of building web solutions out of web
parts. So for us at Google, as we--everybody
has been stressing at this conference the
Web is the platform and we do lots of cool
technologies. So one more cool Google technology
is Google translation which I'm sure many
of you have seen, especially on the results
page where we say, translate this link. That
same translation technology about six months
ago, I believe, some time last December, became
available to Google talk users as wired chat-bots.
So now, you can invite this chat buddy who's
a 'bot' and you type it to him in English
and he will type back at you in the language
of your choice, so and, there are 'bots' for
each of the language translations that we
support. So then, that's our next piece right?
So now, where is the chat-bot most useful?
The chat-bot is most useful in two contexts,
when you are chatting with somebody whose
native language you don't speak, or when you're
doing email. And email and chat sort of go
so well hand in hand, that those two things
are integrated in the Gmail interface. So
in December, January, Charles and I used the
AxsJAX framework to make the Gmail interface
work fluently. So then we had that, so now
we had Gmail talking through all the screen
readers, self-voicing browsers, using the
underlying Aria [INDISTINCT]. Gmail, because
it's a power-user app again, everything can
be done from the keyboard so we didn't even
have to add keyboard support. So now, let's
put the pieces together. You have Gmail, you
have chat, you have translation and we had
speech output. Suddenly, you sort of connect
the dots, this thing turns into, you know,
your friendly neighborhood interpreter that
comes along for free and translates for you
from one language to another and not just
translates by showing you the text on the
screen, it speaks it. So let's do the demo.
>> CHEN: Okay. So, right now I'm in Gmail
and I'm going to go to the chat area and start
chatting with the bot.
>> COMPUTER: [INDISTINCT] <mgchf.talk.cable.com>online
new chat message, press escape to ignore the
message. Press any other key to open a chat
window mail.
>> CHEN: Okay, so, now, I've loaded up a chat
window with the translation bot and I'm going
to type a message.
>> COMPUTER: [INDISTINCT].
>> CHEN: Okay. And we'll see what it says.
>> COMPUTER: Welcome to [INDISTINCT].
>> CHEN: So, as you can see, it can translate
that and it speaks it.
>> RAMAN: So, you know, it's interesting.
It goes back to web 2.0 is all about building
web things out of web parts. And in this case,
Google has built a bunch of interesting pieces
that are all exposed as web parts, namely,
Gmail, namely, Google Talk, namely, translation
and chat bots. And what AxsJAX framework has
done is it's added to this mix a web block
that allows you to speech enable, access enable
web applications. And so when you take that
block in with the rest of the file and do
what we as web developers do, which is mash
them up and you get a talking interpreter,
which, if I told you up front, can you develop
me a talking interpreter as a web application,
it sounds like an daunting task. But by standing
on one another's shoulders as opposed to another's
toes, you sort of get a very powerful infrastructure
from doing such thing. We have about 10 minutes.
We can do more demos or we can take questions.
So if there are people who have questions,
raise your hands. Otherwise, we'll show you
a few more demos and codes.
>> CHEN: Okay, no questions for now.
>> RAMAN: Yeah, so, we have no questions?
>> CHEN: We have no questions.
>> RAMAN: Okay, so, we'll--I will show you
another interesting mash up, which is the
xkcd comic. This is an interesting example
of, again, bringing information from different
parts of the web to form an integrated whole
that doesn't exist. So, for those of you who
are familiar with Randall's xkcd comic and
for those of you who aren't, since most of
you are web developers, I suggest do a Google
search--this is a comic strip which you will
highly enjoy as somebody who likes technology.
And, you know, you're probably a geek. If
you're a geek, you'll love xkcd. So, the xkcd
comic, Randall has these very nice sketches
and a small caption that goes with the comic.
It has, you know, a caption, if you can also
see the sketch. A more detailed textural description
there would actually be very nice for a blind
user, but would actually detract from the
value of the comic for everybody else. Now,
there is another task on the web that needs
a full transcript of that comic--namely, search.
And there is a completely separate site that
is independent of xkcd and all the other comics.
That is a comic bot search engine where volunteers
go in and type in detailed transcripts of
comic episodes and then the author of the
comic goes and approves them and then they
become live and then there's a search engine
that allows you to search it. Now, we looked
at that and we said, "You know what? As an
end user, since both the transcripts and the
comic are on the web, you can clearly--if
you have the time and patience, go open a
comic, look up its ID, then go look up the
transcript for that comic strip in that other
engine and then go read it." It's too much
work, right? A good programmer is a lazy programmer,
and we all like reading comics. So, we basically
build a mash-up that essentially pulls the
transcript of the comic that you have opened
from this other site, and then use the AxsJAX
framework to speak it. And so suddenly you
can get xkcd becoming a talking comic with
transcripts coming off the web. There's another
example of, you know, building a web thing
out of the web parts.
>> CHEN: Okay, so, I'm going to load up this
xkcd comic and we'll see what happens.
>> COMPUTER: xkcd sandwich transcript. A man
is sitting on a couch, talking to another
man. They are both stick figures. First man:
"Make me a sandwich." Second man: "Make it
yourself." First man: "Sudo, make me a sandwich."
Second man: "Okay." Comment: "Proper user
policy apparently means 'Simon says.'"
>> RAMAN: So, we go out and say, "Sudo, make
me lunch and get lunch for my guests. Sudo,
extend lunch until 2:30." So, we had a couple
of announcements to make from the organizers.
Lunch has been extended to 2:30. Somebody
must have said, "Sudo, postpone lunch." And
the other thing is there are evaluation forms
that we would like you to fill up so we get
some feedback on the session. That's pretty
much what we have. We have about six or seven
minutes for questions. Otherwise, we can get
an early lunch.
>> CHEN: Oh, yes, you there.
>> You've shown us a lot of examples of spoken
and written language, are you doing the same
with sign language?
>> RAMAN: I think...
>> CHEN: The question was about whether or
not we're doing anything for sign languages.
>> RAMAN: Yes. So, for the video, the question
was, "We are doing a lot with written and
spoken, are we doing anything with sign language?"
Right now, we aren't, but I would love to
see work in that space. If you have expertise
in that space, we would love to see some,
you know, open source development in that
space. And, as I said, the AxsJAX framework
itself is not limited to speech or the written
language. Today, it has calls in it for speech
because that's what we've built. The way we
are building the framework, and every line
of code in this framework has been written
this way, is to first build a real prototype,
build a prototype and then build a second
prototype and then see what commonality is
there between those two and then re-factor
it and pull the common code into a framework.
So, not a single line of code in this framework
has been written because we thought it was
a good idea to have it in a framework, it
was because we saw ourselves writing that
same piece of code again and again. And I
would love to see similar things for sign
language emerge. Okay, I--clearly, I don't
have much expertise on that space, but...
And I'm sure--and, clearly, there are many
people in the world who have expertise on
that space, but it would be nice to see.
>> CHEN: Yes. And if you contribute any code
to AxsJAX, we do have a strong policy of rewarding
everyone who does that with an AxsJAX shirt
much like this one.
>> Do you have any insights on how to make
geographic information in the form of maps
more accessible or useable? I work with transit
data and oftentimes transit providers will
just create a whole new--create a long textural
description of the route, but if there was
a way of using the Google Maps API for those
instructions, it would be cool.
>> RAMAN: So, yeah, you were using a mike,
so I suspect the video got the question, but
the brief summary was, thoughts on making
geographic data and transit data more useable
in a nice [INDISTINCT] environment. There
are a bunch of things you can do. My current
favorite is actually to go pull the KML file
for a route and then extract a good spoken
description out of it. That actually works
remarkably well. There are other things you
can do with the Java script player and using
the Maps API. For instance, the kind of lens
demo that we showed you would be a very interesting
thing to do in the context of maps for a low
vision user. From a blind user's perspective,
I haven't seen anything better yet than sort
of going step by step through the textural
directions. It would be nice to do something
with tactile displays, but tactile displays
are enormously expensive. To give all of you
a little bit of context in that space, unfortunately,
the only tactile displays that really exist
out there are sort of dynamic Braille displays,
and they tend to be very expensive. So, I
was in an accessibility conference about five
months ago and they were showing a tactile
display that was a grid of pins that was,
you know, about 360 by 240 pins that they
wanted a cool $20,000 for. That's too much.
So, there are two issues with respect to geographical
data/information, which is,
what kind of queries do you as an end user
make out of such information, and then how
do I give you the answers to those queries.
So, the display part is both, in some sense,
if you think about it as a tactile display,
it's both about answering the questions about
what is here on this map as well as giving
me an interface for posing the question, which
is I go touch a part of the map and ask what
is there. Now, given that tactile display
technology is expensive, my view of building
innovative solutions in this space is to actually
give the user the ability to query intelligently.
So, the reason why I like the KML handle into
Google Maps is that I can do a query of the
form, pizza and, you know, my home address
and then go look at that and then ask for
textural directions from there and then ask
what is near that. Which if you think about
it, if I show you a graphical map, that is
what often your eye is doing. There are other
things that your eye is doing with things
like street views, such as saying, "I am now
facing the Moscone Center and, oh, that building
is over to the right. I need to go that way."
That, I don't have an answer for yet for myself.
I would love to have that.
>> How do you extract the textural data from
the KML site?
>> RAMAN: I do an XSLD transformation. So
that was actually checked into my other open
source project, which is Emacspeak. It's a
talking extension to Emacs. So if you just
Google for Emacspeak, it's Emacspeak with
one S, you will find a point where it's also
checked into Google code. And if you are just
interested in the textural directions out
of the KML file, again, it's checked into
SVM. So, there's a URL for it, you can just,
you know, look at that XSLD file in your browser
and look at it. It's very easy to do. So you
basically take your map, go do a traditional
search on Google Maps and then &output=KML
as a CGI parameter and it will serve up a
KML file. And KML is fully documented on the
code Google com site. It has a lot of useful
information in it including heading and all
of these things. But for extracting textural
directions, I've already written the XSLD,
so you can just steal it.
>> CHEN: Okay, and we're done.
>> RAMAN: Thank you.
>> CHEN: Okay, and if anyone's interested
in trying to develop with us, we do have a
limited supply of CDs, so just catch us now
or later on in the hall, and if we still have
some, we'll give them to you.
>> RAMAN: As I said, all of the codes of AxsJAX
framework is on the website, but what we have
on the CD is a stand-alone Firefox that has
been configured to talk, so you can experiment
with it without actually changing your default
Firefox profile.